good afternoon and welcome to the
National Press Club my name is Andy
Mollison I think if the in-house wanted
to be turned down a little bit I think
it in here microphone thank you my name
is Andy Mollison I'm chief political
correspondent in the Cox newspapers
Washington bureau and president of the
National Press Club I'd like to welcome
my fellow Club members and their guests
in the audience today as well as those
of you who are listening to this program
over one of the more than 350 national
public radio stations or watching on one
of the 2600 cable systems affiliated
with c-span the cable satellite public
affairs network now before going any
further I'd like to remind our members
of some upcoming luncheons the future
luncheon speakers will include former
New York Times editor in foreign
correspondent Harrison Salas Barry on
December first presidential hopeful
jesse jackson on wednesday december
second arms control negotiator
ambassador paul knit see on december 15
federal trade commission chairman Daniel
Oliver on December 16 Italian Prime
Minister Giovanni goriya on December 17
and navy secretary james webb on january
13 i'd like to remind those of you in
the audience that if you have any
questions for our speaker today when I
trust you will please write them on the
cards that are furnished at your table
and pass them up to me and I'll ask as
many as time allows now I'd like to
introduce the guests at our head table
and I ask our guests to please stand
briefly when their names are read and I
also ask the audience to withhold your
applause until I've read all the name
we'll start with mark r owner of Gannett
News Service
Jerry I to zap of the Chicago sun-times
Nathaniel Nash of the New York Times
Linda Feinberg executive assistant to
the chairman of the SEC Thomas Rick's of
the wall street journal Susan ruder an
attorney and the wife of our speaker and
on my right Gil Klein of media general
newspapers the chairman of the Press
Club speakers committee Jesse Stern's of
the Stern's news bureau she's the member
of our speakers committee who organized
today's luncheon Richard Ketchum
director of the division of market
regulation at the Securities and
Exchange Commission Elaine Povich of the
Chicago Tribune and Dave advice of the
Washington Post
today's speaker is David sturtevant
ruder he was born in Wausau Wisconsin in
May nineteen twenty nine and five months
five months later the stock market crash
on august seven 1987 Supreme Court
Associate Justice Antonio Scalia swore
in mr. rooter is the 23rd chairman of
the Securities and Exchange Commission
the time lag between great moments in
your life and stock market crashes seems
to be narrowing chairman Reuter was a
faculty member at Northwestern
University Law School from nineteen
sixty one to 1987 and for one about one
third of that period between 1977 and 85
he was dean of the school of law and
perhaps best known to many of his fellow
Midwesterners for the affirmative action
program that he put into effect there
not only for minority recruitment and
for recruitment of those such as women
who have not traditionally had access to
careers in law but also to the follow
through through bar examination tutoring
sessions and and so on that meant that
the people not only began but that they
as a schooling but that they actually
entered the profession in addition he
taught at the University of Pennsylvania
law school in 1971 and was a faculty
member at the salzburg seminar in
american studies in 1976 his life work
has been in law and education and
planning and he's been described as one
of the few new SEC chairman who actually
knew the names of the laws he was
supposed to administer before he took
office on August seventh person who
prepared my notes for this then writes
on this introduction on Black Monday he
made a statement I don't have it
and it was you recall during last
month's market collapse I act intrigued
me so I looked it up and I found
Monday's today's New York Times comes
through as always with answers to every
conceivable question you have here is
from a story by Jeff guru last month's
market collapse was felt internationally
the immediate declines range from
fifteen percent in Tokyo to twenty-two
percent in New York and London in more
than thirty percent in Hong Kong david s
ruder the chairman of the Securities and
Exchange Commission spoke last month
about the need for better international
regulation in the wake of a six-fold
growth in world capital markets over the
last six years mr. reuters speech on
October 19 the day of the collapse went
largely unnoticed well since this is a
calmer day at least it was the last time
i looked at the wire okay then i think
maybe we have time to hear some of the
message and that's why and we are very
happy that mr. rooter whose name by the
way his german name which means rudder
that pose makes him the helmsman for the
rest of the Reagan administration at
least in the Securities and Exchange
Commission to give us some idea of
what's up and what can be addressed what
is being addressed at the Securities and
Exchange Commission I think the problem
that he faces are the challenge he faces
the opportunity our best foot in one
sentence at the bottom of the first page
of the advanced text of his speech for
today it states the views expressed
herein are those of chairman ruder and
do not necessarily reflect those of the
Commission other commissioners or the
staff under these challenging
circumstances we are pleased members and
guests to welcome today's speaker David
Sturdivant Rueter the 23rd chairman of
the Securities and Exchange Commission
mr. Mollison members of the press club
members of my staff over here and
friends it is a great pleasure to speak
to the National Press Club I have now
been chairman of the Securities and
Exchange Commission for slightly more
than three months and it is time for me
to identify publicly those securities
regulation issues that I believe should
be addressed by the Commission in the
months ahead in doing so I recognize
that recent market events are creating
their own agenda impelling the
Commission to determine why they
occurred and whether they reveal
problems that require regulatory changes
but there are also other important
matters that demand attention in
fulfillment of our responsibilities to
maintain the integrity of our capital
markets and to protect the investing
public let me identify five areas of
concern first the need for regulatory
changes to meet problems posed by the
October market break second matters
relating to the internationalization of
the securities market third potential
repeal of the glass-steagall Act fourth
the regulations of insider trading
finally means of improving protections
for securities industry customers by
reciting those five areas of interest i
dint do not mean to exclude other
important areas such as our strong
enforcement program tender offer
regulation and the corporate structure
questions inherit in the one share one
vote proposal what I do intend is to
point out that we are in a unique time
in the Commission's history and in the
regulation of securities markets in the
United States I would like to review
with you today some portions
of a remarkably full agenda first the
October market break let me discuss the
market events of October as everyone
knows on October 19th the Dow Jones
Industrial Average fell a record 508
points this day was followed by two
weeks of extraordinary volatility on the
new york stock exchange as well as in
the over-the-counter markets on the
American Stock Exchange and in the rest
of the world's leading securities
markets while much attention has been
focused on the events of those two weeks
it is important to keep in mind that the
dial had already fallen 158 and then 235
points in the two weeks preceding the
week of the 19th at the clothes on the
16th the dow was down twenty three
percent from its augen August 1987 high
of 2736 on October 19 the dow closed at
seventeen thirty eight thirty six
percent down from august and October
thirtieth the towel closed at nineteen
ninety three twenty-seven percent off
its 1987 p as of last friday the dow was
at nineteen fourteen thirty percent
below august level although these deep
clients were dramatic it is significant
that the 1987 August high on the Dow was
almost four times it's August 1982 level
of 776 and 20 and 24 percent over its
January 1987 level in addition to the
extreme volatility during October the
daily volume was extremely high prior to
friday October sixteenth the New York
Stock Exchange had experienced only one
day with volume over 300 and 300 million
shares on Friday October sixteenth
volume increased to three hundred and
thirty eight million shares and during
the week of October nineteenth volume
was over 600 million shares on two days
and averaged 362 million shares on the
other three days the Commission is
deeply concerned about the impact of
recent market volatility and large
volume on public investors on market
professionals and on the structure of
the market itself the Commission study
now underway will review the role played
by various market participants during
October we will examine the various
forms of trading involving stock index
options and futures so-called arbitrage
trading and portfolio insurance although
these new products are benefited
institutional investors and the people
whose money these institutions manage
they also raise serious concerns the
Commission's study will address a number
of important questions in this area
including first to what extent did index
related trading contribute to the market
decline our preliminary information is
that index related trading occurred in
significant amounts on October sixteenth
October 19th and october twenty however
it is too early to conclude precisely
the extent to which this activity
contributed the market decline second
how have institutional portfolio
strategies been affected by the ability
to use stock index futures and options
to adjust stock positions more quickly
and more cheaply than by trading stocks
more specifically did institutions
increase their stock positions to the
point that they were more likely to make
selling decisions as the market moved
onward third does the ability to take
the equivalent of a very large stock
position to futures and options with
relatively lower initial deposits result
in unacceptable levels of speculative
activity in the market in other words
should higher margin requirements be
imposed on derivative index products
the study will also cover other
questions raised by the October events
we will look closely at the adequacy of
dealer capital to cope with increased
volume and volatility and hope to
suggest means for making more capital
available we will also examine the
market markets operational capacity for
order execution order routing and
clearance functions although as a
general matter these systems operated
well during the market break we will
study the strains that appeared during
this period to determine where
improvements may be necessary as part of
an examination of operational capacity
we will also focus upon the treatment of
retail customers during the crisis
finally we plan to study the
relationships between the various
foreign and domestic market during this
time during October we experienced a
market-wide sell-off accompanied by
unprecedented volume these events tested
the efficiencies of the markets trading
systems personnel and settlement
operation I believe the systems and the
industry handled this crisis quite well
under the circumstances nevertheless we
have witnessed the most dramatic and
volatile market decline since the SEC
was formed unraveling and analyzing the
events of the past weeks is a high
commission priority I am committed to
determine what course of action should
be taken in light of these events in
order to ensure the continued protection
of investors and the financial and
operational soundness of the Securities
in the state internationalisation not
only will foreign markets be part of our
study of the October market break but
internationalization generally will
demand special attention by the
Commission in the coming year the
increasing internationalization of both
the markets for offering securities
initially and for trading them after
their initial issuance is a recognized
fact particularly for debt and
increasingly now for equity securities
as well because the enforcement of our
regulations and the surveillance of our
markets are
more complex tasks tasks in an
international environment the Commission
already has completed negotiations for
bilateral email information sharing and
enforcement assistance agreements with
regulatory authorities in the United
Kingdom Japan and Switzerland we expect
to work out more such agreements in the
coming year the clearance and settlement
of transnational trade that is the
exchange of money for securities after a
chain after a trade has been agreed to
has lag behind the development of active
trading markets and there are still
considerable delays in clearing and
settling trades in many countries this
has been an area of commission attention
in recent years and we will continue to
do all we can to facilitate further
improvement in this area an equally
significant international ace to the
internationalization problem is that
caused by the difference between our
regulations and those of the growing
foreign markets in this area the
Commission's primary responsibility must
be to maintain the investor protection
regulations that make our markets fair
and efficient and therefore competitive
while adapting our regulations to an
environment where as a technological
matter trading can now move anywhere in
the world your prospective regulatory
initiative in this area will be
commissioned consideration of proposals
to permit active trading in the United
States among large institutions of
certain securities of foreign issuers
without requiring additional disclosure
this initiative will be coupled with
continuing attempts to develop
internationally compatible accounting
and auditing disclosure insider trading
general anti-fraud and manipulation
standards
in a larger sense internationalization
is one of the several major developments
that has emerged in the past 20 years as
we have witnessed changes in the
fundamental nature of securities markets
beginning of the 1960s and into the
early 1970s the markets became in the
industry jargon institutionalized this
means that during this period trading in
securities gradually became dominated by
large institutions such as pension funds
institutional trading generally involves
the more frequent trading of larger
blocks of securities than does
individual trading the late 1970s and
early 1980s witnessed increasing
innovation in industry in securities
industry services such as automated and
computerized trading systems as well as
in securities related products such as
stock stock index futures and even more
complex hybrid instruments markets also
be claimed became increasingly
internationalized during this time these
factors all interrelate in a complex way
thus institutionalization and automation
of markets have in part caused
increasing product innovation and
internationalization in turn creating
increasing interaction between markets
these very fundamental changes in the
nature of securities markets have found
our ultimate negative expression in the
events of the Blessed October it would
be counterproductive to go back into
time to abolish or limit
institutionalization innovation or
internationalization of market in any
event these factors cannot be considered
individually responding solely to enter
an internationalization or to innovation
is no longer sufficient rather the
responsible regulators task in coming
year will be to determine whether the
changing nature of securities markets as
a result of the combination of these
factors requires adaptations to our
regulations including adaptations than
might make the regular
among domestic and foreign futures and
securities markets more compatible with
one another glass-steagall one fact of
life and international securities
markets is that except here and in Japan
banks are free to engage in the
securities business our restrictions on
banks may soon be alleviated however
since the glass-steagall Act which
directed strict barriers between
commercial and investment banking as a
response to the depression of the 1930s
is now under serious attack since the
passage of this law developments in the
financial markets have eroded commercial
banking traditional lines of businesses
and have brought securities firms
increasingly into competition with
commercial banks in many areas in
addition because glass-steagall applies
only to activities within the United
States some United States banks are
engaged in broad investment banking
activities overseas pointing to the
increased competitive pressure on banks
and two banks extensive overseas
securities activities some have
advocated that United States banks
should be allowed loud to engage in full
service investment banking in this
country they argue that allowing banks
to engage in all securities activities
will actually improve the safety and
soundness of the banking system by
allowing banks to diversify their
business and increase their capital they
also argue that bank entry into
securities activities will increase
competition in financial services
benefiting consumers some also assert
that regulation relaxation or repeal of
glass-steagall is necessary to make
United States banks competitive with
foreign bank
opponents of the glass-steagall repeal
argue that will it that it will increase
the level of risk in the banking system
and result in an unacceptable
concentration of economic power
opponents also argue that repeal will
create serious investor protection
concerns concerns which were which are
of great importance to the Securities
and Exchange Commission advocates of
increased bank securities powers respond
that the protections of the federal
securities laws which also were enacted
largely in response to the stock market
crash of 1929 are adequate to deal with
any concerns regarding investor
protection and the securities market
just last week two versions of proposed
financial restructuring legislation were
introduced in the Senate both bills
would amend portions of the
glass-steagall act the Commission will
testify on these bills on December 3rd
and our testimony necessarily will
reflect our views as the federal agency
with responsibility for the protection
of investors and the maintenance of fair
and orderly securities markets as the
federal agency with this responsibility
we have a crucial interest in the proper
regulation of the Securities activities
of all participants in our nation's
capital markets including depository
institutions from this perspective I
believe that banks should not be allowed
to engage in the securities business
unless they are subject to securities
and exchange commission regulation to
this end the Commission has strongly
supported the proposed Bank
broker-dealer Act which would require
that banks engaging in broker-dealer
activities do so through separate
affiliates subject to commission
regulation it also supports the bush
task force group recommendation to
consolidate in the commission
administration and enforcement of the
securities registration and reporting
requirements for all publicly owned
banks and
we are currently examining the various
issues involved in proposed
glass-steagall repealed including issues
related to the recent market event the
Commission has important regulatory
responsibilities in the securities area
and we must continue to be able to
fulfill these responsibilities should
banks be allowed to participate more
broadly in the securities industry
insider trading yet another issue
critical to the fairness of our
securities markets and the protection of
investors is the regulation of insider
trading in its early development insider
trading referred generally to the act of
purchasing or selling securities by
persons who possess material nonpublic
information about a corporation or its
securities in breach of a fiduciary duty
to the corporation and its shareholders
recently insider trading concerns have
been expanded to encompass a broader
range of activity including trading
while in possession of material
nonpublic information that has been
misappropriated insider trading
prohibitions are extremely important the
operation of our securities markets
because they improve investor confidence
in the fairness and integrity of the
securities market the investing public
has legitimate expectations that the
prices of act actively traded securities
reflect publicly traded publicly
available information about the
financial condition and prospects of
this year issuers and that persons with
access to material nonpublic information
will not abuse their trust by trading
before such information as publicly
disclosed the Commission in recent years
has aggressively pursued insider trading
violations we have brought insider
trading cases not only against so-called
traditional insiders such as corporate
officers and directors but also against
professionals such as investment bankers
risk arbitrage ors brokers attorneys
other law firm employs accountants and
bank officers we have also actively
pursued cases involving tipping of
associates relatives and friends last
week two highly significant events
occurred in the development of the law
against insider trading first on Monday
the Supreme Court announced its decision
in the winans case involving misuse of
confidential information by an employee
of the Wall Street Journal in that case
the court left undisturbed a federal
circuit court holding that trading on
the basis of misappropriated non-public
material information violates the
federal securities law the Winans
decision is a significant victory for
investors and the integrity of our
market second on Wednesday of last week
the Commission transmitted two senators
regal and D'Amato a commission approved
bill that codifies traditional insider
trading prohibitions and also
incorporates a misappropriation theory
based upon breach of duty concepts the
Commission's proposed bill would
prohibit the use of insider inside
information that is wrongfully obtained
or used and would broadly defined such
wrongful conduct it includes the
definition of insider trading that
reaches not only insider trading by
corporate employees but insider trading
by brokers and other persons associated
with the market by friends and relatives
of insiders and by other persons who
knowingly violate relationships of trust
and confidence by utilizing inside
information for their benefit
congressional action on the pending
insider trading legislation will
determine for a substantial time into
the future the content of federal
regulation of insider trading I hope the
end result of these deliberations will
be a determination that it is wrong to
benefit oneself bribe reaching a duty to
keep information confidential when this
breach threatens the fairness and
integrity of our securities markets a
legitimate
federal regulatory interest arises
customer protection another area of
particular concern is that adequate
protections be offered to customers of
broker-dealers one of the first
proposals that became came before the
Commission after I became chairman
related to the arbitration process
governing disputes between brokers and
their customers the Commission voted to
approve the many recommendations for
improvement of this arbitration process
the arbitration recommendations the
Commission made were aimed at the
ability of customers that have disputes
with our brokers resolved with
procedural fairness the Commission's
concern with the integrity and fairness
of the securities market also reaches
substantive customer protections and in
this regard the Commission will seek to
ensure the strict enforcement of
prohibitions against sales practice
abuses and other forms of overreaching
by brokers these essential essential
customer protections are found in the
federal securities law and rules as
willingly as in the rules of the
exchanges and the National Association
of Securities Dealers which operate as
the ethical guidelines of the industry
these rules reflect the fact that
brokers occupy a special position of
trust and confidence in their
relationships with our customers among
other means of improving customer
protection I intend to heighten the
Commission's enforcement efforts in this
area to encourage the industry to
enforce its own ethical prescriptions in
a diligent way and to cooperate more
with the states in the performance of
their critical role in this area one of
my major concerns as chairman will be
that customers be treated fairly and
believe they are being treated fairly as
I stated in the outset by setting forth
five areas of concern I do not mean to
diminish the importance of other issues
to which the Commission will be devoted
if the tension that coming
year these include tender offer
regulation the one share one vote issue
competition in the options market
disclosure in the municipal securities
market legislative initiatives including
amendments to the trust indenture Act a
variety of accounting issues including
opinion shopping mandatory peer review
and the recommendation of the National
Commission on fraudulent financial
reporting proxy regulations and mutual
fund advertising all these issues are
significant fortunately the current
commissioners and the Commission staff
possess the high levels of knowledge
competence and judgment necessary to
address dress this agenda I considered a
privilege to serve on this commission at
this time and to have an opportunity to
help develop with the other
commissioners the staff and the Congress
the overall regulatory approach that
will best serve our nation's interest
lots of question your regulatory cousin
the commodity futures trader Trading
Commission said that their preliminary
data showed little index trading during
the week of October 19 another
questioner says the CFTC has reported
that index arbitrage contributed to only
nine percent of New York Stock Exchange
sell orders during the market crash so
are you using is the SEC using a
different set of numbers what accounts
for this the Securities Exchange
Commission is cooperating with the CFTC
and the gathering of data we are not yet
complete in our data gathering process
and neither is the CFTC as I understand
their report we we have found that
during the morning of October 19th there
was significant index arbitrage trading
and that during the day on october
twenty there was significant portfolio
insurance selling i use the word
significant because it is a weasel word
it's a word that does not commit me to
fight indicating what our conclusions
will be we are studying the question
carefully and at this point I can
neither agree nor disagree with the
CFTC's conclusion
we're little investors protected on
Black Monday in other words did they get
a fair shake the question of the
protection of small investors on Black
Monday and indeed during the week of
October 19th is one that we are
concerned with we we know that in many
cases the small investors were not able
to reach their brokers that in many
cases the small investors were not able
to reach their mutual funds and we are
concerned in addition with some order
reading order routing and the execution
problems with regard to small investor
orders we whether or not it's a matter
of unfairness is of course a judgmental
question we had extremely unusual volume
on on Monday and Tuesday of the
nineteenth and twentieth 600 million
shares was roughly twice as much trading
as has ever occurred on the New York
Stock Exchange and in the various
markets so that the breakdown of these
systems I think could have been expected
to even a greater degree than it did
occur and we we will be of course
looking to see whether there was any
deliberate activity on on the part of
brokers to to put the small investors at
the back of the line my tentative guess
is that we were looking primarily at
some systems breakdowns which happen to
affect these small investors more
dramatically than the large one
do you support the proxmire darn bill to
repeal glass-steagall my remarks on
glass-steagall this noon indicated that
we are still studying the question of
repeal of glass-steagall I will be
testifying on December third regarding
that repeal I I can repeat again what I
said in my speech that the Securities
and Exchange Commission believes that in
that in an important condition of
glass-steagall repeal is the
establishment of the principle of
functional regulation that is that when
banks engage in securities activities
they must be regulated as in the same
manner as other members of the
securities industry and we will be
seeking appropriate legislation to to
ensure that result number of variations
on a question which is in this case to
better keep up with the growing
interrelationship among Securities and
future markets that you spoke of should
the SEC and the CFTC be merged into one
regulatory body the question of CFTC SEC
merger was quote settled in 1982 by an
accord between by then chairman Johnson
and by my predecessor the chairman shad
at the Securities and Exchange
Commission they agreed essentially that
the products labeled futures would be
would be administered by the CFTC and
products labeled options would be
administered by the Securities and
Exchange Commission in 1982 at the time
that a court took place derivative index
products that is products in the futures
market which were had a direct
relationship to prata to the stock to
stock trading we're not in
in any great man and I think that we are
going to be looking carefully at the
question of whether of what and how that
those products should be regulated but I
do not think that we will necessarily be
driven to a position that says that we
must we must discourage Exchange
Commission must regulate must regulate
those products or that the CFTC and the
SEC must be merged what's going on right
now is that we are increasing the degree
of cooperation between the CFTC and the
SEC last week my staff met with the CFTC
staff by in the presence of acting
chairman Hyneman and myself and we on a
rather formal basis ask each other what
we can do to make sure that our lines of
communication are open that our
cooperation is enhanced so that
regulatory objectives can be taken care
of in the near future should we have a
repeater near repeat of October 19 I'm
hopeful that those regulatory
initiatives and the cooperation between
the two agencies will be satisfactory
and I I really can't to make a stronger
statement about what the regulatory
pattern should be again until we
finished our study sort of a variation
and a follow-up on a previous question
while you you say that you would like
any securities underwriting by banks
under the SCC's regulatory umbrella you
in general agree with the arguments for
or those against banks interest entry
into Investment Banking
you must remember that I'm a lawyer so
I'm quite willing to say on the one hand
and on the other hand and in the in the
context of of that repeal of
glass-steagall there are some questions
of macroeconomics which need to be to be
settled much of the much of the
investigation and the discussion thus
far has been with regard to bank
protection from our point of view in a
macroeconomic way we are quite concerned
that some of that some aspects of
securities industry protection be
addressed for instance if banks are
allowed to hold securities affiliates
it's quite likely that banks will be
restricted in the amount of money that
can be loaned to their affiliates that's
on the one hand and on the other hand if
these banks own affiliates there may be
significant questions as to whether or
not the banks will be willing to loan
money to non affiliates in times of
liquidity crisis problems like that need
to be examined from the securities
industry and the securities markets
point of view in in in in ways which
which are quite complicated so I guess I
have to say on the one hand I would
support a grass Stegall repeal if
everything is satisfactory on the other
hand I would oppose glass-steagall
repeal if it's not satisfactory I know
that in itself is not a satisfactory
answer but I do think that that this is
an extremely important matter which is
going to be examined very very very
closely in the next few weeks if you
want to stay tuned until December third
Congress is requiring us to have an
opinion by then so we will have one if
you believe that the system handled the
crisis quite well do you believe that
more regulation of the markets is really
necessary the answer is do I think that
since the system handled the market is
quite well additional regulation is
really necessary my preliminary
observations are that some additional
regulation will be necessary we need to
find ways to be sure that the clearance
and settlement the procedures of the
broker dealers are adequate to meet
high-volume days we need to be concerned
about the order routing systems so that
they do not break down on high-volume
days we need to be concerned about
telephone access by customers to their
broker dealers and to their mutual funds
we need to be concerned most importantly
about the availability of broker capital
my tentative conclusion is that the
question of the liquidity of our markets
is one which needs to have extremely
important attention whether or not a
conclusions relating to improvements in
broker-dealer capital will require
additional legislation or regulation I
do not know but I do concern consider
that to be the crucial question for
examination
brings us to the next question which is
has the SEC found any major security
firms which lost a significant amount of
capital during or since the crash my
very able staff under the guidance of
Rick Ketchum has told me that their
inquiries in the broker-dealer area have
revealed no major firms that are in any
trouble this statistic has been
confirmed to us by the new york stock
exchange you might be interested to know
that during the during the crisis week
of October 19th our staff organized
itself into into groups and we had we
had people in direct contact with the
major brokerage firms of the United
States so that practically every hour
during these periods we were able to
confirm or check on rumors with regard
to one form or another during the period
of October 19 and 20 particular that the
street was was rampant with rumors that
one one form or another was in serious
trouble we were constantly calling those
firms calling us in New York Stock
Exchange and obtaining information and
we did not find during the market crisis
that there were major brokerage firms in
serious trouble we had as you know some
smaller firms that were not able to
handle the problems we had the true
specialists on the new york stock
exchange and two specialists on the
American Stock Exchange who were not
able to survive they were acquired by
other companies and their specialist
functions continued
this questioner says why should the SEC
be concerned about the
internationalization of the securities
market why not let those international
markets work out their own problems if
the fact is that internationalization is
here whether we like it or not there is
an enormous amount of activity taking
place in the overseas markets it began
in the dead area in which American firms
went overseas to borrow it is continuing
in the equity area since the so-called
Big Bang of last spring in in London in
which the of the city the acronym for
for Wall Street in London was
deregulated there has emerged in in
London and in it in a very large market
for securities that market is is trading
in in international issues as well as
trading in some of our major American
issues at the same time we've had the
emergence in Japan of an extremely large
and well capitalized market there are in
Japan only four major broker-dealer
firms these firms are extremely well
capitalized and that market proceeds
with the depth and liquidity which is
very strong what is what is happening in
in the international markets is that
some of the demand for securities
transactions which exists in our in the
United States is going overseas and at
the same time our markets are not able
at this point to to deal with the you
know the problem of attracting overseas
securities to to our to the United
States we have disclosure restrictions
which are important barriers
they're bringing these securities to our
markets one of the things that I talked
about in in my remarks was the
possibility that we may be able to find
a way to bring these securities to
market here even in a restricted
institutionalized market but
nevertheless to provide a vehicle for
that training the other the other point
which is extremely important to
understand in the international
internationalisation area is that
automation is here to stay we have now
in this in the United States developed
automated quotation systems last Christ
reporting systems routing systems
clearance and settlement systems and in
some case X cases execution systems all
of these systems are taking place in the
United States in an automated way and
what's occurring now is that these
automation systems are being developed
overseas with links between our markets
so that inevitably what's going to
happen in the future is that as private
enterprises begin to develop automation
of securities systems we're going to see
our security sold in international
markets a greater depth and liquidity
with our with our securities and
international markets and we are going
to be faced with both regulatory and
competitive problems in the
international area in the futures market
area in the futures trading area it's
clear that that the futures trading a
derivative index products trading will
exist in overseas markets and that if we
tamper I think that if we tamper too
much with our own markets we're simply
going to see that the activity move
overseas with the possibility again of
having an unregulated markets over there
my view is that the Securities and
Exchange Commission needs to cooperate
with regulators overseas we need to
convince the regulators in foreign
markets that one of the reasons that our
markets are so good so strong so say
is that we have a regulation I'm pleased
to tell you that that in the insider
trading area we have found countries
more willing to adopt insider trading
legislation to put their regulation more
in line with ours so that we have the
equivalent of equal regulation oversee
so that's a long answer the short answer
is at these two markets our markets and
international markets are inexorably
linked does that mean that you yourself
have no questions about the wisdom of
the Chicago Mercantile Exchange as joint
venture with Reuters to trade futures
electronically 24 hours a day around the
world
when you ask a former law professor that
he does he have no questions I could
answer that question quite easily of
course I have questions the the proposed
the proposed links is one which raises a
strong regulatory concerns we need to
have conversations with CFTC we need to
look at our own our regulatory powers
and be sure to the extent that we can
that those markets are not subject to
manipulation that those links are
carefully scrutinized and as I said
before we are currently in the process
of trying to find out the extent to
which derivative index products that is
the futures trading such as occurs on
the Chicago Mercantile Exchange have
unduly interfered with our markets in
times of high volatility this questioner
says EF Hutton revealed this morning
that it isn't talked about possibly
being acquired in part or in whole was
it pushed into those talks by lack of
capital I have no information on that
subject one can assume that there will
be a continued concentration in the in
the brokerage industry as I said before
I think that that the availability of
capital is really what what what will
push our markets and if if a firm begins
to find itself without available capital
I I could certainly assume that it would
seek emerged upon I have no specific
information about he had fun
it struck me these question been rather
relentless good I really I've never
quite asked so many intense ones in a
row all year of a speaker and this is
marvelous Joe you come and you haven't
faded started out with my birthday at
the gratiot this questioner wants to
know if you could explain why the sec
came close to deciding on october twenty
seconds to request the delay in the
start of futures trading on our cover
twenty-third yes i can on on the more on
the on the morning of october twenty
seconds the the futures of Standard &
Poor's 500 futures index was an opening
was at a an extremely extreme discount
numbers I think that we're extremely
unusual i think it was sixty 60 points
down from from where it had that hike
that's that was as as large as one could
ever have imagined and we we we looked
at that opening and saw that that what
was happening in the securities markets
on the New York Stock Exchange or what
might happen at the new york stock
exchange would be that people looking at
what the futures market seem to be
predicting for price the futures people
will tell you that there's a price
prediction feature move contained in
there in there in there in there index
and that the futures that predicts price
price discovery is the word they use and
one could imagine that that at the in
the market in New York Stock Exchange
that someone trying to figure out where
to open a stock on on New York Stock
Exchange looking at a futures market
which seemed to be down dramatically
would decide that they had to open their
their their products down
in and buy an enormous number our
thought was that if we could allow the
the stock products to be opened without
having the overhand hang or threat of
the psychological factor at least of
this of this large discount appearing on
the on the various screens around the
country that that it might produce a
more orderly opening we we discussed
this with the we discussed this in a
securities and exchange commission
meeting on the afternoon of the 22nd we
were told during that meeting that the
Chicago virtual work Mercantile Exchange
had introduced price limits and we
decided that that that we that we could
postpone the any formal request for the
introduction of a delayed opening on the
on the futures exchange we did consider
it for the reasons that I that I've
indicated but we did delay on that
Friday morning and we found during the
next week that the problems did not
reappear and we have not since suggested
that solution
one is a very general question which
basically asks you whether the twin
deficits had anything to do with what
happened on October 19 that's the first
did this we at twin deficits to have
anything to do with the decline on
October 19 I don't know what I do know
is that on October 14 15 and 16 we had
seen dramatic declines in the market
Friday October 16 we had a decline of
over 100 points which was an enormous
decline I may say that during the week
of of October 19 I began to be used to
this they say how's the market doing
well only down 50 points those kinds of
numbers were so unusual in the earlier
days that we would have been astounded
but we began to be used to this higher
volatility of in any event on that we
had a hundred point decline on october
nine sixteenth and over the weekend
there was a confluence of economic news
not only concentration on the twin
deficit concentration on interest
matters and we had if you remember the
attack in the Iran Gulf a series of
economic and and geographical or other
reviews events that may well have
continued we've contributed to to a
decline I I can't put my finger on one
or the other matter however as Lee is a
cause
I'd like to ask a question myself here
from in your talk you said the Winans
decision is a significant victory for
investors and the integrity of our
market do you see any offsetting effect
in the views of some that it was a
significant defeat for those who wanted
First Amendment freedoms for the press
you want me to answer that question in
this room about the year and a half ago
I appeared on a panel in San Diego at
its securities Institute's to discuss
First Amendment protections in the
context of the securities laws and I
dealt with both the low case and the
proposed and the Winans case the low
case as you remember was up before the
Supreme Court I I did so with the help
of my a very able wife attorney Susan
who helped me with the outline and we
jointly predicted the result in in low
and and made a prediction regarding the
result in in winans result we predicted
in winans was that since insider trading
involves a disclosed or abstain rule
First Amendment protections were really
not involved what is what is going on in
insider trading is that it is the act of
trading that triggers the prohibition so
we weren't we weren't in
the least our view was that the insider
trading prescriptions do not in any way
interfere with free speech they simply
say don't do it don't trade we don't say
don't talk in faith in in fact the
insider trading doctrine is a do talk
rule we think disclose and then you
won't have to worry about the about
insider trading prescription I'd like to
thank you very much for answering so
many questions and short enough in short
enough answers that we could ask even
more I hope not too many future speakers
realize that's what would happen to them
also oh my so I think certificate of
appreciation we have here for you for
speaking to us today and in addition we
had a committee assigned to designer
press club lapel pin and then we
assigned the work and had it staffed out
and have it done by a commission we
ended up with a press club paperweight
and we'd like to present you with one as
a souvenir of your appearance here thank
you very much